back now on cbs mornings at 8 30 as
tributes are continuing to pour in
honoring former miss usa
chesley crist police believe the former
attorney and entertainment correspondent
took her own life on sunday she was
known as a light who inspired others
with her strength crist a former miss
north carolina was crowned miss usa in
2019 and was known as an advocate for
mental health her death is fueling a
renewed conversation about the
importance of talking about mental
health and to help us with that we're
joined now by psychiatrist dr sue varma
dr former thank you for being here
whenever a famous or public person takes
their own life you start asking what did
you miss and with chesley in particular
no one can come up with anything and it
makes us all wonder
what are people really going through and
when you have a strong friend who you
think is fine how do you reach that
person when from the appearances
everything is fine yes you know it's so
hard and i think what we really need to
do is really keep in close frequent
contact with people and it's so easy
these days i think number one with the
pandemic we're not socializing in person
and also because of social media makes
us feel as if we know what's going on
and we say oh i checked up on them and
they said what do you mean i looked on
their instagram and everything is fine
they're doing a photo shoot and they're
going out with friends but what we're
missing is really deep vulnerable
questions where we ask somebody how are
you really really doing are you okay and
probing questions where there's both
sides of us each person is emotional and
involved in emotional disclosure but why
would we ask those questions to follow
what tony said the people who were close
to chesley those of us who knew her
are really it's true racking our brains
to say what did we miss why would you
even think to ask something like that
when there are no apparent signs none
you know and gail when we see somebody
and we say they look so put together we
don't ask what did it take for them to
hold it together
you know and we don't realize that all
of us what we call the iceberg effect we
only see the success we only see the 10
that's above water we don't recognize
that each of us really is struggling
with something in our lives and the
question is how much how deep and how
dark what what does a research show on
something like this because i tell you
when i say i'm haunted by it i really am
extra did a beautiful tribute to her
last night that just brought many many
feelings as i was watching it
what does the research show when
somebody does this out of the clear blue
sky for us it's so sudden
but does it show that they had been
probably planning this for some time yes
now when we look at risk factors of
suicide usually we're talking about
somebody who has a history of depression
now there's something called high
functioning depression where it's not
your typical person can't get out of bed
or is not functioning not showing up to
work they're showing up but it's at such
a large cost so you have this history of
depression where they might feel
worthless or guilty they might be
ruminating but they're not sharing it
with you and then there might be a
trigger there might be something acute
that happens and then they make an
impulsive decision so the planning has
been there it's sort of like brewing and
then it's like some catalyst happens and
there's an impulsive reaction to that my
heart goes out to her family yes close
friends absolutely
in this time
what do you say to them how do they heal
because this is something that they're
going to have to really grapple with
yeah emotionally the rest of their lives
i keep thinking about her mother and her
her family her siblings her mom yeah
step dad her father yeah and she had a
lot of siblings and she had five
siblings yes you know it's so painful
because we're going to go through
different stages of grief and any time
we lose some a loved one there's grief
but this is even more complicated
because you're talking about a young
person beautiful inspirational mental
health
advocate role model for the community
a person of color and this really
touches me deeply because as a
psychiatrist in the work that i do i
always ask myself what could i have done
differently right just in general and
even as a friend as a daughter i ask
myself and one thing i want to say is
don't beat yourself up you're going to
want to go back and play monday monday
morning quarterback hindsight everything
is 20 20. right oh i could have i should
have we should have done this yes all we
can do is move forward with this
information as a public health
announcement is check up on people ask
them the deep questions make time for
them distraction free eye contact even
if it's uncomfortable even if it's like
help me with this sue how does someone a
person who seem to have everything
gorgeous smart lots of friends great job
well liked how does someone like that
get to feel so alone so desperate and in
such despair you hit it on the head gail
when you said alone we are dealing with
an epidemic of loneliness and that was
before the pandemic loneliness has
nothing to do with the number of people
that you're surrounded by it has to do
with the quality of connection do you
feel understood and i think the more
famous you get it becomes harder to feel
safe it feels harder to understand
because you don't know who's got your
back and you're always competing there's
a lot of pressure there's a lot of
expectation and for women body image
issues to feel that there's a
timeline on our beauty on our youth on
our contributions and i remember reading
something about her saying a statement
that there's you know a finite limit to
this she was dealing i don't know her
and i don't know what she was dealing
with but there was a lot going on yeah i
would imagine
there is a cure in those deep
undistracted eye contact conversations
with people in your life a text message
doesn't cut it for a conversation like
this dr sue varma thank you very much
thank you
if you or someone you know is seeking
mental health resources now you can call
the national alliance on mental health
helpline at 1-800-950-6264
and if you're in a crisis right now you
can text nami n-a-m-i to 741-741